hello my name is Justin and I am new to
the chess website um but I'm here to
teach you guys chess so let's go ahead
and get right into it today I'm going to
talk about the two nights opening so
this is one of the most common openings
in chests and a very great place to
start doesn't matter what level you are
if you're a master if you're beginner
this is a great opening to play so it
starts with E4 this is the most common
move E5 and then white brings their
Knight out to attack our Pawn in the
center so we want to defend that pawn so
we play Knight to C6 we bring another
piece into the party and now we defend
the Central
Pawn and in response to this most white
players play Bishop to
C4 so this is kind of how we get to the
two knights opening we play Knight to F6
and as you can see we have two knights
out that's you know hence the the name
two knights opening and these Knights
are great because in the opening you
want to control the center and both of
these Knights uh do a great job of
controlling the center um so again this
is a great opening no matter the level
because it's based on the opening
principles so here there's a lot of
things that white can do um and we'll
look at a few different options but kind
of the most uh advantageous and seen a
lot at the lower level is the fried
liver attack with Knight to
G5 so right away white is being super
aggressive moving a piece twice in the
opening which is considered not great
not giving attention to their other
pieces um but what they do do is they
attack this Pawn on F7 so we need to
figure out how to defend it and it's not
so easy there's not a great way to
defend that
pawn none of our Knights can defend that
pawn none of our Bishops it's really
difficult to defend we defending it with
our King but that's not good enough
because they have two attackers and we
only have one Defender so
now the only move to maintain equality
in this position so this is very
important is to play D5 it's to block
this Bishop from reaching this F7 Square
so this is a very important move to
remember um and even if you don't
remember it's important to remember why
like we're playing this move so that
they cannot take on F7 take on F7 would
be really bad because they're going to
Fork Our Queen and Rook with the Knights
so D5 is very very
important and then after D5 white will
just take it um otherwise you know we're
attacking their Bishop putting pressure
on the E4 Pawn um
so after uh we take on
D5 or sorry after white takes on D5 now
um black also has a few options here so
in this
position um a very common move from
black is to play Knight to D5 Knight
takes D5 but this is actually a mistake
so it's not a mistake because
um it's not protected it is protected if
white were to take we would just take
back and that would be an even trade but
the reason this is bad is because white
has a really crazy sacrifice Knight
takes F7 so they sacrifice their Knights
and the only reason they do this is to
bring our King out until the open it's
just left out to dry they're going to
play Queen F3 check they Fork the king
and the Knights and it's very difficult
for black to do anything about this if
they just go back well white just want a
free Pawn because they won this Pawn on
F7 and then they traded a knight for a
knight um so if white or sorry if flock
really wants to keep this
extra material he has to be very
advantageous and very scarily go out to
this E6 Square where the king is really
pushing it uh really pushing the limits
as how far your king can go because it's
very out in the open and because your
king is such an important piece having
it that open is very very risky so
White's going to play Knight C3 put even
more pressure on this guy they're just
going to Castle blast the center open
with D4 at the right moment um and white
has very good play again because this
king is just in the center without much
protection at
all so let's go back um instead of
Knight Tak D5 again we don't want to
take this Pawn on D5 because it allows
Knight takes F7 so instead of this I'm
going to show two other options for
black that are good or better um so
first off um the main line and when I
say main line I I mean that like the top
players in the world consider this the
critical Line This is what they're
playing and this is what they consider
to be the best um so the top players in
the world play Knight to
A5 and what this does is it gets out of
this attack while simultaneously
attacking this bishop here on C4 so
after Knight to A5 um white w
to preserve this bishop so they play
Bishop to B5 check if they were to just
move this bishop anywhere if they were
just to retreat it then we could take on
D5 and our king would be a lot safer so
for example say they Retreat it
here we would take on D5 and then this
Knight takes F7 just isn't as strong
because we can block with the Knight
there's no pin on the Knight anymore
with his Bishop on that diagonal so the
king is actually quite safe so if we go
back Knight to
A5 white tries to continue to be
provocative by playing Bishop to B5
check looking at our King so we had to
block it um Bishop to D7 is an option
but the best move is actually
C6 and C6 is actually a Gambit he lost
this Pawn on D5 and we're saying you can
go ahead and take another Pawn we're
going to take one back but you're up a
pawn like white is up a full Pawn but
block does have a lot of compensation in
return so at first it doesn't seem very
clear like what is Black's
compensation but the more you look at it
the more it becomes obvious white pieces
are all very
clumsy if we start with like
H6 Knight to H3 is actually kind kind of
one of the best moves which is crazy
because from H3 it can't go to either of
these squares and it's just it looks so
ridiculous out there and Knight to F3 is
also problematic because E4 and then the
Knight goes to E5 and we just gain more
time harassing this Knights could play
Bishop to C5 or Bishop D6 a lot of good
options here and um white can can get
into some trouble here Queen to D4 um um
is a nice idea in the position as well
so that's why
um C6 is considered uh a pretty strong
idea here and I also want to mention if
the bishop went back to A4 this would be
even worse because the bishop on A4 is
not protected anytime there's an
unprotected piece we want to be able to
take advantage of that so first we start
with H6 again it's the same thing but
after the Knight um goes back to F3
there we go um E4 is very strong because
E4 attacks the knights and the Knight
again doesn't have a lot of squares um
it would get trapped if it went out to
H4 and then if it went back to E5 like
we just saw Queen to D4 again attacks
the undefended pieces both the Knight
and the bishop are undefended and the
queen attacks both
simultaneously and white can do nothing
to to save it so looks like Bishop takes
C6 is scary it's easy to get caught up
with our opponent's ideas but after
Knight takes C6 Knight takes C6 and a
simple move like Queen C5 or queen
D5 this Knight is going to be trapped it
has nowhere to go and we're winning a
whole
piece so just to recap of the fried
liver after Knight to G5 we're going to
play D5 to interpose this diagonal and
then after D5 um there's a whole lot of
other options but the best is to play
Knight to A5 to chase that Bishop away
and then once it moves you block with C6
gambiing a pawn and then you just
prioritize your development Bishop moves
back now here this Knight is in a very
awkward spot so we want to kick it
around first and then once we kick it
around a little bit now we play Bishop
C5 ready to play Queen D4 and Castle all
right so let's look at a different line
so from the starting
position another line to look at is if
white plays Knight to C3 this is very
common again especially at the lower
level but it's already a mistake it
allows a very nice trick in the position
for black so
take a minute and see if you can figure
it
out black is going to play Knight takes
E4 it looks like white just defended
that pawn right that was the whole
reason they played Knight to C3 is to
defend that pawn but the problem is when
the Knight takes back on
e4 the issue
is these pieces are both
unprotected and they're both vulnerable
to attack so we can Fork them with D5
we're attacking both of them at the same
time and we're just going to win a pat
back at the end of the day like for
example say they Retreat and they take
their Pawn back at the end of the day
we're going to be better because we have
this Pawn in the center and they don't
have any Pawns in the center so we have
better control of the center giving us
the advantage so again after Knight C3
we have this Center fork trick something
else that's important to mention after
Knight takes E4 white can try something
like Bishop takes F7 essentially saying
I know my Bishop's going to be lost so I
might as well take a pawn and ruin your
castling in the process but after this
trade black is still going to play D5
and white can give you a check but your
king is going to be pretty safe on G8
and what's going to tell the the story
here is this huge Center White just
cannot compete with this Center this is
the ideal Center we have both of our
pwns in the center controlling Central
squares um this is very very nice and
our pieces are going to come out to very
good squares this bishop can come out to
G4 Bishop C5 um it's just a very
comfortable position for black even
though our King looks a little risky
it'll be okay we can kick this Knight
out we can bring our Queen to protect
our King
there's no real
danger so um that was Knight to C3 and
then the other thing is sometimes white
just says I want to get my king out of
the center as fast as possible and they
Castle but this is just a mistake
because after this we can just take this
Pawn right that's why we played Knights
F6 was to attack this pawn and they
didn't defend it so they might try to
you know develop a piece you know attack
our our Knight in the center but we can
just play
D5 D5 is such a crucial move because if
we move the knights um then white would
be able to take on E5 since their Rook
is now looking at that square but D5
both protects the Knight attacks this
bishop and cements this Knight on a
beautiful Square um it's just the
central control again is fantastic this
is what we want out of the two kns open
so castles is not anything to worry
about so I'll leave you with probably
the best line um the best line here is
for white to play D3 again this is the
main line this is what the top Grand
Masters in the world are playing they're
playing D3 here and then after D3 black
should play Bishop to C5 develop their
Bishop out they're going to play D6 next
um just continue their development
controlling the center as well so white
castles and then after
D6 again we're just trying to get that
Bishop out white usually plays H3 and
then here is something I also want to
note we could Castle here but I find
that when people Castle here they tend
to forget about something important so
for example if the castle um I'm just
going to flip through a few moves to
show what could happen there's nothing
wrong with castling but it can lead to
this kind of pin and the Knight coming
to D5 and this happens a lot and it
causes serious serious problems for
people so this is what we want to avoid
and this is why we play H6 first we just
avoid this bishop coming to G5 altoe and
we're ready to finally castle and finish
our development this position is very
equal
cool but this is kind of what the top
players are playing um the only
Improvement that you know people are
making here is potentially playing C3 C3
is aimed towards pushing D4 and claiming
the center in the future but again play
would follow very similarly D6 um
potentially H6 castles Etc so that was
the two nights opening feel free to
comment below if you have any questions
and have a great rest of your
day